y
[Música]
avance informativo de france 24 el
presidente de eeuu job aiden partido
desde la base han ruso y rumbo al reino
unido- en el inicio de un viaje de ocho
días a europa el primero desde que
asumió el cargo y con encuentros claves
en la cumbre del g7 y en ginebra donde
conversará con su homólogo ruso vladimir
putin antes de partir el mandatario
anunció que durante su gira presentará
una estrategia de vacunación global para
poner fin a la pandemia pero no dio
detalles esta noche del air force one
aterrizará en torno al de ese reino
unido donde el jueves se reunirá con el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
desde el viernes participará en la
cumbre del g7 de tres días y luego irá a
bruselas donde hablará con sus socios
europeos
el viaje acabará en ginebra suiza el 16
de junio con su primer encuentro con el
presidente ruso vladimir putin
hoy hay movilizaciones en la capital de
colombia la toma de bogotá fue convocada
por el comité del paro nacional que
acusa el gobierno de iván duke de usar
una estrategia de desgaste de la
protesta para acallar las movilizaciones
que iniciaron el 28 de abril en su
contra las autoridades critican que la
ciudad tiene casi el 30% de casos de
kobe del país y las unidades de cuidados
intensivos están operando casi al 100%
de su capacidad entretanto human rights
watch denunció abusos gravísimos de la
policía con denuncias creíbles de 68
muertes 34 de ellas confirmadas en el
contexto de la protesta la ong dijo que
la reforma policial anunciada por duke
es superficial agregó que también hay
casos graves de violencia por parte de
individuos
la ong temblores presentó un informe a
la misión de la cdh en colombia
denunciando el disparo indiscriminado de
armas de la policía
en marruecos el ministro de exteriores
naser purita afirmó que el gobierno
español le trata de europeizar una
crisis que es bilateral y negó que la
salida de ese país del líder saharaui
brahím ghali resolviera el conflicto
purita dijo que no se puede prohibir el
separatismo en tu país y fomentarlo en
el vecino a mediados de mayo marruecos
dejó de evitar el paso ilegal de unos
10.000 migrantes a nado incluidos
cientos de menores al territorio español
de ceuta en el norte de áfrica así rabat
mostrado a su queja porque galli quien
busca la independencia del sahara estaba
en españa recibiendo tratamiento por
kobe el líder del frente polisario
partido el primero de junio a argelia y
mañana el parlamento europeo votará una
moción sobre la utilización de niños por
parte de las autoridades marroquíes en
la crisis con ceuta
el viceministro de relaciones exteriores
de rusia serguéi riabkov dijo que
quedaban pocas cuestiones pendientes por
resolver en las conversaciones para
reactivar el acuerdo nuclear con irán
agregó que ya no quedaban obstáculos
insuperables según reportó la agencia de
noticias ria las potencias mundiales han
estado negociando en viena con irán y
eeuu para revivir el pacto de 2015 según
el cual de teherán acordó frenar su
programa nuclear a cambio del
levantamiento de las sanciones
internacionales y que donald trump
abandonó unilateralmente en 2018 re
imponiendo castigos y motivando a
teherán a aumentar su enriquecimiento de
uranio
francia y bélgica e iniciaron hoy una
nueva fase de alivio de las
restricciones de la pandemia en parís
los ciudadanos disfrutaron del servicio
en el interior de los restaurantes y la
disminución del toque de queda que ahora
inicia desde las 11 de la noche también
los bares y cafeterías podrán ofrecer
servicio en sus mesas en el interior y
reabrieron los gimnasios por su parte
bélgica se despidió de las mascarillas
al aire libre y amplió los horarios de
bares y restaurantes con servicios en el
interior la gente puede ir a la oficina
una vez por semana y el entretenimiento
también se reactivó
y así llegamos al final de este avance
siga con nosotros en france 24 y en
france 24 punto com buenos días
[Música]